[Music]
albert einstein has been credited with
saying
creativity is intelligence having fun
we can only guess what einstein might
think about the artificial intelligence
now being used to help create
modern works of art and that term has a
broad
definition from painting and sculpture
to music
and even the written word brook silva
braga met some of the humans
bringing these ai creations to life
okay venus de milo i recognize her ben
snell
starts out with a library of 1200
classical sculptures
yeah i got a seizure at some point you
would find winged victory
and tells a 90 computer to study them
and i ask it to try to find connections
between the sculptures and distill them
into their most basic forms
a machine learning algorithm churns for
about a day
and then snell tells it to design a
sculpture itself
how many tries do you give it i just
give it one this is it
this is it this was the first one at me
he turns the computer off
chops its bits into bits and then casts
that computer dust into the sculpture
it itself dreamt up the device's
creativity
for lack of a better word and my
creativity are inextricably intertwined
we're beginning to have dialogues with
these machines
[Music]
we're also singing duets holly herndon
trained in ai to harmonize
on the album frodo
programmers coaxed a machine learning
network into painting
portrait of edmund de bellamy christie's
sold it for 432 thousand dollars what
you're seeing now are
all the sensors i have on my head
alexander rieben taught an
algorithm to interpret his eye movement
and brain waves
it judges what pictures he likes best so
that's what it landed on for this round
and uses his preferences to create a new
portrait
i think an interesting question that
arises from this is do we value
art made by people more than we're going
to value art made by a machine
to test the question he's intentionally
blurring the line
this is a sculpture described by the ai
programming a computer to type up art
ideas
that he executes himself the first
plunger is simply a normal plunger but
the rest represent a series of plungers
with more and more of the handle removed
it also creates a back story the work is
now considered a landmark of conceptual
arts and it was even featured on an
episode of seinfeld in 1997.
i then asked it to create a seinfeld
script and it did just that
elaine hits george on the head with a
plunger and there's an argument about if
it's art or not it's quite funny and
you could you could definitely see it as
a seinfeld tint to it
yeah the things it comes up with seem
creative which again is what surprises
me
but it's not creative right or is it
it's a good
question i mean that's it's a kind of a
philosophical question probably doesn't
have imagination but maybe it has
something
different that we don't even have a name
for maybe it has a different way of
thinking
here i am talking right now like it has
this or it does that
even knowing these systems i find myself
you know putting
putting animal-like or human-like
attributes into them artists emphasize
that general artificial intelligence an
independent conscious machine that's a
long
way off for now machine learning
networks simply find
patterns in existing work and with human
help
spit out a variation on the theme it's
like we have found a way to get a bunch
of stuff that humans did
and give it hand so it can type or give
it a mouth so it can talk
what would this pile of screenplays type
if it were able to type a screenplay
oscar has directed four short films
written by a name
i don't want to be honest with you you
don't have to be a doctor
i'm not sure but when sharp trained his
ai writer on action films for the
forthcoming bobo and girlfriend
what came out was mostly a commentary on
what went in
turns out though when you turn on the
machine that you've trained on lots of
action movies
uh it spits out white hot misogyny all
of the dudes
doing all this super tough guy stuff and
you know blowing things up and killing
people
and the female lead doesn't even get a
name yeah bobo basically assaulting this
this woman whose name is literally
girlfriend hey girlfriend
this is one of the big concerns about
this technology though right it just
reflects back humanity and maybe
humanity needs to be improved upon
it's a fairground mirror that shows us
ourselves and it exaggerates things that
we maybe were ignoring
the machines aren't just training on
human art but being trained
by human engineers are they artists now
enter the human lawyers if you make an
algorithm
that can produce paintings and i use the
algorithm to produce a painting
whose painting is it it might be both of
ours harvard law's jessica field points
to the case of that edmund de bellamy
painting
made and sold by the french art
collective obvius
using a toolkit made by american teen
robbie barrett
they did not credit me and um you know i
was not mentioned and they i didn't get
any of the money
as a legal matter does robbie barrett
have a claim to any of that money
this is all in dispute right now does he
have an argument that that he's entitled
to
to a portion of the ownership of that
work yes
we found so much of this generative art
is ultimately a commentary on our
relationship to machines
this was a computer and it made this
for ben snell an appreciation of what
they do for us
creating the sculpture is affording the
computer a body
and what he says they'll never do alone
ai can write poetry
but you can't have a conversation with
it you can't understand why it made what
it's made
i don't think purely generative work
will ever have the same
place in our heart that regular sort of
traditional art does
in the tradition of the greek god who
mutilated himself and was reborn as a
tree
snell named the sculpture addis
for cbs this morning saturday brook
silva braga new york
i actually shot a story of a computer
that wrote
a musical in london it never aired
yeah one of the computers in this before
we did too but i'm not sure they make a
whole lot of sense
i feel like it's this round circle
conversation as they were saying and
if you created the technology that then
makes the beautiful art whose is it
all of that should we just make the
remaining 45 minutes of the show it
could be right
you just keep going around meta style
yeah it could maybe the
compute the a.i yeah that would be good
the movie part of that was fascinating
about all the violence and then all the
girls actually maybe they're onto
something